plenty of news today thanks in large
part to
the fact that kyle shanahan and john
lynch spoke to the media today about
the trade that will put the 49ers in
position
clearly to draft a quarterback that's
one big takeaway we're going to listen
to what they had to say miles
but it's obvious beyond obvious
they moved up to number three to get a
quarterback if there was any doubt
there shall be no doubt they're up at
number three to get a quarterback
they admitted it plainly uh today in
that press conference that that is what
they traded up to number three overall
in order to do they wanted to draft a
quarterback they want to get somebody
who can lead their franchise for the
next
however many years and as much as they
keep trying to compliment jimmy
garoppolo and say we believe in jimmy
and all these nice things
obviously they feel like they have to
upgrade at the position otherwise
you don't do what you did and that was
obvious from the moment that the trade
was reported but i i you know i don't
know how much credit we want to give
them
for admitting that before the pick is in
but they did do it today so yes it is
now very clear
what they have done and why they've done
it there's no downside in admitting it
they don't move up to number three if
they're not perfectly happy with whoever
is left
after trevor lawrence and zach wilson
come off the board and if for
some reason some reason there's a team
out there
that must have mac jones and the jets
are willing to give up zack wilson and
get whatever else they're offered
so someone else can get mac jones 49ers
take zach wilson no skin off their butts
i mean that's
so they're in position to get lawrence
wilson or
if it's jones whoever it is that they
moved up there for they're going to get
one of those three guys
and that's fine with them they're
willing to invest three first round
picks and a third round pick
for that player let's hear from shanahan
and lynch earlier today regarding the
trade and regarding
the supposed franchise quarterback who
at some point will no longer be on the
team
you know we both spoke to to uh to jimmy
kyle kyle did right away
and then i did later in the day um you
know i think i think the
i'll let kyle go after this but uh you
know the the message was what we were
doing
why we were doing it and how he is very
much still a pla
a part of our plans and uh you know um
i'm not not gonna um you know i believe
those conversations
uh should remain private but but uh
jimmy
um he welcomes competition and so i
think
i'll leave it at that and kyle you go
ahead um yeah very similar
um you know wanted to get it to jimmy
definitely before it came out so
um called him first thing had a good
conversation with him you know it's
obviously no one wants to hear that um
and i know that he wasn't
totally excited about it like you'd
expect but um jimmy handled it great
like he always does um we were very
straight up with each other and
i told him how he felt this doesn't mean
this isn't changes
any of his circumstances right now i
mean he's still coming in here trying to
lead this team
i told him how excited i was that free
agency went a lot better than we
anticipated with being able to
sign a lot more of our own players than
we had thought going into it
and that we got a real good team coming
back here and we still plan on him
leading us and getting as far as we can
with them
plan on we plan on he's still part of
the plans john lynch tried to hold it
together
but he was sliding off of the horse
and got kyle to come in and save him i'm
sorry
i i am a student of demeanor of word
patterns
of body language everything john lynch
was trying his damnedest to sell us
something
that they're incapable of selling
themselves nobody came out and said he's
our starter this year
all these people the media he's our guy
they're our god he's our guy anonymous
source tells shefty on friday he's still
our guy
did either of them speak with that kind
of unequivocal zeal about jimmy
garoppolo today
hell no miles hell no he's still in the
plans and you know what the plan is
to try to get some idiot to trade for
him well he
basically they said he's still in the
plans for this off season
and i don't know if it was exactly in
that clip but at some point in that
press conference that's literally
what they said the off season and in
that clip i think kyle shanahan used the
infamous
words right now so this is something
that we're going to obviously see
happen over the course of whether it's
before the draft
during the draft after the draft and
maybe right before the season after
training camp
at some point i think they are
anticipating that jimmy garoppolo
will not be on this team for the rest of
the 2021 season
it just it would be it basically became
inevitable
from the moment that they executed that
trade and said we're going up to number
three to select the quarterback
they have then basically decided that
jimmy garoppolo is
more likely than not not going to be on
the team anymore at some point
before the regular season or maybe
during the regular season but i think
it should be before the regular season
because they're on the hook for a 25
million dollar salary
and it's gonna cost them less than three
million dollars in dead calf
if they just straight up release him so
to me there's not much
there's not much sense in keeping jimmy
garoppolo on the roster throughout the
entire regular season when that's the
kind of math that it is
and also you're you're doing this
because
at some point you don't necessarily
believe that jimmy garoppolo is the
quarterback of the future
otherwise you wouldn't trade up and give
up all that draft capital to get up to
number three in the first place mike
yeah that's the one thing that i can't
get away from and i try to keep things
as simple as possible because anything
more than that hurts my brain
you give up three first round picks and
a third round pick in an off season when
there's been all this discussion about
three first round picks for deshaun
watson
three first round picks for russell
wilson you're not investing three ones
in a three
for someone who's going to have his ass
planted on the bench
for multiple years or even for one year
i said this today on 95
7 the game in san francisco it's like
when you get a new
toy for christmas you get a remote
control car what do you want to do
miles as soon as you get the remote
control car
do you want to keep it in the box for a
year or do you want to take that damn
thing outside
and use it and you're in pai i'm
speaking from experience you're
impatient while the damn battery charges
can the battery charge faster
oh it's snowy and it's icy out i might
ruin the car
i don't care i'm playing with this damn
car
i wanted it i got it and i'm using it
and that's the mentality
you don't make that investment for a guy
that isn't part of your plans right now
it's one of the reasons why sims is
convinced
matt jones is the guy because he's the
most game
ready and you wouldn't give up three
ones and a three
for a guy that you have to develop
quietly behind the scenes you just don't
do it you get somebody else
you stick with jimmy g you trade for
deshaun watson
yeah not that not that russell wilson
would be traded by the seahawks to the
49ers but it's not unprecedented
donovan nab was trading the division
drew bledsoe was traded in the division
it's not it's not a a rule it's not a a
commandment
thou shalt not trade a quarterback
within the division so you want somebody
to make an impact now
and it's mac jones i believe and he's
starting this year
and the rest of it is just details don't
give me this stuff that he's playing
in 2021 and miles i don't know
that i want him to at this point i i
it's too weird right now you're gonna
bring in this guy who's gonna suck
all the oxygen out of the room right you
got to make him the guy
you've already told the world this is
the guy
this is the future of the franchise this
is the savior of the super bowl
potential winning 49ers you can't bring
him in and just put him in a closet and
slam the door and say well we'll bring
them out next year it just doesn't work
that way
i think the other part of this it kind
of just reminds me of what happened
with the eagles in 16 when they drafted
carson wentz
and they had sam bradford and they
talked about sam bradford bean starter
and all that
for a really long time and i believe it
was labor day weekend
when they finally traded him to
minnesota and then
from there on it's like boom yeah carson
wins is the guy carson wentz has beaten
out sam bradford carson wentz has shown
all of these great things
in training camp and we just believe in
carson wentz and obviously five years
later it's a totally different story but
at the time that's really what they did
i almost feel like the 49ers are trying
to run
that playbook basically say yes we have
jimmy garoppolo
we like jimmy garoppolo we think we can
still win jimmy garoppolo is still going
to give us the best chance to win
and then they're hoping that at the end
of august maybe
there's going to be some team that's got
a really terrible quarterback situation
and they are going to want to bring in
jimmy garoppolo and then they're going
to give up a premium draft pick for it
that
to me sounds like what's happening right
now because you can't convince me
that they really really believe that
jimmy garoppolo was going to be the
starting quarterback for this team
throughout the entire 2021 season that's
not what happens
when you trade up to draft a guy
believing that he is going to be your
franchise quarterback
miles excellent point and the nfl is a
deadline driven business
as far as the 49ers are concerned with
jimmy garoppolo as long as they're
content to have the 25 million dollar
cap charge arising from his compensation
this year
on the books the deadline is
the weekend the regular season begins
that's when
as a practical matter the base salary of
a vested veteran
becomes fully guaranteed what happens is
if you've got four more years of service
and you're on the roster active roster
week one
and you get cut at any point after that
you can take the balance of your pay
unreduced by anything you earn elsewhere
as termination pay
you have one time in your career you can
do it with 25
million in play jimmy garoppolo would do
it that's
when the 49ers need to make the decision
to
i think as you said not that long ago
poor get off the pot
so that gives them months months
to hold on to jimmy garoppolo and see
what happens
and yeah look teddy bridgewater
catastrophic knee injury
late august 2016.
one and a four falls out of the sky
manna from heaven
into the eagles clutches for a guy that
they otherwise would have benched at
some point during the 2016 season for
carson wentz if wence didn't start
week one so there's no rush none
whatsoever
unless and and see this is why it's like
the trent brown situation
with the raiders and the patriots
because i was surprised when trent brown
agreed to take less money and the
patriots traded for him because if
you're trump brown
you say to the raiders i'm not reducing
my pay i'm not cut me
and they say fine we'll cut you when we
feel like it and so the 49ers
can hold on to jimmy g until labor day
weekend
or someone can work out a deal where
they give the 49ers something
and jimmy g takes less money and they do
the trade now and they just sit back and
wait for that but no one's paying this
guy 25 million this year
it's not happening folks 25 million in
an environment with a reduced cap for a
guy who's missed 23 games over the last
three years
it would be idiocy for the 49ers to pay
him 25 million so i think we're on the
same page
i think that if anything today
made me feel even more strongly that
there's no way garoppolo is going to be
on that roster week one
unless he agrees to a significant pay
cut and potentially
isn't the starter to begin the season or
if he starts the season he's going to be
supplanted not long after that
let's hear kyle shanahan talking about
attending alabama pro day two
they had pro day one last week mac jones
through he's throwing again tomorrow and
shanahan's gonna be there here's what he
said
i normally don't like to go to him a
bunch unless i feel i need i have to
unless i have to for some reason but
i also have been kind of grown up in the
idea that
you don't like to go everywhere and show
people things and when you're sitting at
12 and stuff i don't
want to go to a bunch of quarterback pro
days and things like that
now that you move up to three you don't
have to hide as much it's not as big of
a deal to me as it might have been when
we're sitting at 12.
remember this is the guy whose dad
drafted jay cutler in 2006
and had never done anything to create
any impression that he was in any way
interested in jake cutler
no visits no interviews no meetings
it was out of the blue and i think the
broncos traded up with the rams
if i'm correct and there is a very
strong chance i'm not
but that's the skullduggery that you
have to engage in
prior to the draft because anything you
do
anything you say will be used against
you in this competitive environment of
people getting the guys they want
so now that they hold the third pick
because somebody made the argument oh
him
oh this is a smoke screen he really
wants zack wilson not what what no
no or he really wants justin fields no
no one can get them
and if the only way they're going to get
fields or
jones is to get in front of you and that
means you're going to get trevor
lawrence or zach wilson
it's a no-lose proposition they don't
have to be coy about anything at this
point miles
exactly and that's why when they were
talking about it in this press
conference today they said that there
are three guys that they feel
comfortable with
and by going up to three they have
guaranteed themselves one of those three
guys
and so that's why it really doesn't
matter you don't have to have the smoke
screen like you're saying mike
you can do whatever it is that you want
to do to feel as comfortable as you
possibly can
about whoever you're going to select to
be this franchise quarterback for the
next however many years
and i think that that's important
especially in a year like this
where kyle shanahan talked about this
you cannot go
and really have a private workout with a
guy as you normally would you can go and
sit down and have dinner with a guy
as you normally would so instead you see
things like what urban meyer did
down there at clemson during that when
they he had that pro day
for trevor lawrence right you know he
was just standing there so close to him
so
he could hear the hum of the ball coming
out of his hand and all that noise
so i think when you are able to then
just say yes
we're going down there because we're
interested in taking a qb
and it could certainly be mac jones then
you're just basically
you're taking away all the mystery to it
because you know that you can
and it doesn't matter and i like we were
saying last friday i think it was
if the jets don't want zack wilson then
i i don't really know what's going on
because it just seems like that somebody
is gonna have to pry that pick from
their cold dead hands
so and i don't think that urban meyer
would even ever come to jacksonville
if there wasn't a chance of them
drafting trevor lawrence so they
basically know what the first two picks
are going to be
if something happens they're still
comfortable with whoever is going to be
left to them at number three overall
hey miles i suggested earlier today on
pft live and they put up the conspiracy
mike graphic when i said this but i
don't think it's much of a conspiracy
the idea that urban meyer deliberately
didn't go to zack wilson's pro day
because he does not want any doubt
creeping in
he's all in on trevor lawrence and if he
would have stood there
mask on knows out watching and listening
to the ball come out of zach wilson's
hand the way he was moving left to
left to or right to left and throwing
back across his body maybe he would have
started thinking are we sure that this
is the right thing for us to do
and there it is let me just say this
they showed that
graphic within the past couple of weeks
miles and i got an email from one of our
viewers in the uk who said i didn't know
you smoked
cigarettes okay
that's either somebody who knows nothing
about american pop culture or an
excellent job with the photoshop i do
not wear
short sleeved dress shirts so that's
your ultimate proof nor do i smoke
cigarettes
cigars once or twice a week yes
cigarettes no
um i was right by the way somehow
someway
the broncos 2006 they had pick number 15
they packaged 15 and 68 to the then st
louis rams to move up to 11 to get jay
cutler and stunned
everyone that was mike shanahan kyle
learning
from his dad how to be secretive and you
don't need to be secretive now and here
he is you mentioned
some of the things about the mike jones
dynamic with kyle shanahan
shanahan from earlier today talking
about the former alabama quarterback
the way we looked at it is i mean to
move up to three
we had to feel good that there's three
guys we'd be comfortable with leading
our team for a long time
and we couldn't make that decision
before there was three guys
so we had to feel that way with three um
now i think there's a chance to get
there with four and five
there's a chance there's five guys that
are kind of at this party a little bit
and
people are talking about them going
everywhere they're all over in the first
round
our feeling is these guys we're going to
go a lot higher than people realize
and when you have two guys sitting out
one and two possibly could
um even possibly three and four then you
hear a lot of teams
um all the way through the draft who are
in a situation where they really want a
quarterback
and they don't have someone close to
what we have with jimmy um
that means those five guys are going to
disappear pretty fast so we had to feel
confident in three
to make this move and that's what we did
and i do it
i'm excited about now we know there's
five players
who do you want to put your um who do
you want to put
your future at well i'm glad we got a
month to really work on that
boy that well look i i think part of it
too
they all get the memo officially or
unofficially
not to disrupt the element of surprise i
think they know damn well
who they want at this point it's just
checking boxes
confirmation hey look anything can
happen
between now and a month from now
i don't want to throw out possibilities
i don't want to be accused of jinxing
anyone but
anything could happen to make mac jones
all of a sudden
not attractive a month from now there
are a variety of things
that can happen kitchen accidents can
happen that would make mac jones
you know not attractive nine fingers
instead of ten for example
makes mac jones not attractive
especially if one of the fingers missing
is on his throwing hand
so you don't have to say anything and
the league doesn't want you to say
anything
until the pick comes in but i think they
know
miles who they want they don't make this
move without knowing
who they want they just don't want the
right to say well we get the board after
the first two picks are gone they know
who they wanted they wouldn't have given
up that much to get there
no doubt and i'll give you an example so
i worked for the rams in 2016 when they
traded up to get jared goff and at the
time
everybody kept saying oh well you know
it's this percentage or that percentage
or
we're still gonna be able to dive in
here and really make a decision
they knew who they wanted when they made
the trade and you don't trade up to
number one overall
unless you know exactly who you want
okay and in this particular case because
they probably have very good intel
on who is going at number one and number
two overall the 49ers trade it up
to number three overall because they
feel like their guy is going to be on
the board
and then they feel like they're going to
be able to pick that guy i think you
could actually say the same thing
about the philadelphia eagles in 2016.
they had a
pretty good feeling of who the rams were
going to take at number one overall so
that's why they felt comfortable
going up to number two overall with the
browns and then they selected carson
wentz
there's just there's just too much
certainty in these situations that i
feel like you have to have
when you're trying to get a quarterback
that is going to be basically your
franchise savior right you you cannot
just do this thinking well if this
or then maybe we can do blah blah no you
have to be pretty certain in order to do
this
and that's why i really feel like these
guys in the 49ers organization are
extremely certain
as to they're going to get their guy i
love jeff fisher and i love the fact
that he enjoyed
every day every hour every minute and
every second
of having the first pick and not telling
anyone who it was going to be
and you know he'd grow that mustache
just kind of over his mouth and you'd
see there'd be kind of a half smile
hiding behind there you really don't
know what's going on behind that
mustache
he loved it he loved it we all knew
it was jared goff but he loved it
and i look i don't know this for a fact
but common sense tells me
the league office hammers into the team
that has the first overall pick in the
draft
do not do not disclose
what you're going to do because you've
got two types of fans out there
you've got the people who pay attention
to it all the time and know exactly
what's going on
because they're soaking up every bit of
information those people know
for example that trevor lawrence is
going number one to the jaguars then you
got
all these folks who are just kind of
casual who show up for big events like
the super bowl and the draft more show
up for the super bowl but there's a lot
of them that show up for the draft
they don't know they're not following so
if you
say it and it becomes the above the fold
headline on the
sports page if there are even sports
pages anymore and everybody knows about
it gets blasted out to everyone's phone
there's no mystery whatsoever
even if it's a little mystery they like
it so i think that same thing applies to
the jets at two
and it applies to the 49ers at three and
everyone's playing along
to make the draft a bigger deal a little
bit of mystery
even if there's not going to be any
surprise lawrence wilson and
jones maybe not maybe they're not going
to come out and say they don't have to
no they don't have to and they probably
shouldn't that you know it's better for
us maybe if they don't do it you know
and then the people are going to figure
out on draft night oh wow like they
actually drafted mack jones or oh wow
they finally drafted trevor lawrence or
zack wilson and then they come to pro
football talk and
they read our articles about it so i
guess it is you know sometimes better
for us right
yeah hey that's the way it goes we want
to have that mystery drawn out as long
as possible but we also want to be
transparent with the audience because
i mean i i yeah this is where it gets
a little bit dicey because there have
been some
tweets recently that were deleted by
folks who work for the shield
because maybe those tweets were a little
too close to the mark
of letting everyone know exactly what's
gonna happen this gets into the whole
don't tip the pics that's just not on
draft night
that works ahead of time as well they
don't want any certainty out there they
don't want
any clarity they want there to be just
enough
equivocation so we tune in because you
never know what's going to happen you
never know
who's going to have a video posted onto
their social media account by a hacker
with someone in a gas mask bong right i
mean
anything can happen the craziest stuff
you can imagine can still happen
all right um mac jones recently
addressed
the possibility of playing for the 49ers
specifically the 49ers offense here's
jones
on san francisco i've watched their tape
and stuff
i've got a chance to watch a lot of um
you know everybody but 49ers
specifically obviously they run a lot of
wide zone
they also have a great full back so they
can run power and they do a bunch of
good play pass off of that so
outside zone sprint out stuff you know
obviously the drop back passing game is
really similar to what we did with sarc
and you know some of their motions that
they use i noticed they got the
boomerang motions and the cap motions
across the ball fast so
that's all stuff that i'm really
familiar with and obviously it's a super
quarterback friendly offense and they
have great playmakers there
so i'm really looking forward to just
learning more about that
oh and he will oh he will it's it's just
it needs to be a little more coy than uh
than the rest of them and again hey look
tomorrow who knows what happens at his
pro day workout
number two but shanahan will be there
lynch will be there check the box right
this guy won the national championship
he knows how to perform under pressure
he'll have a little pressure tomorrow
to perform with this presumption that
he's going to be the pick
of the san francisco 49ers at number
three
overall number six overall quite
possibly could be
devante smith to the miami dolphins and
the dolphins by trading down and trading
back up
are still in position to probably get
the guy they would have gotten at number
three potentially
anyway hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports